كثير كلام جدي نجوم ردوا على الجدل
فاجئونا باخبار حصريه علقوا على انتقادات
وغيره الكثير كمان انا شايف اني اني اني
احمد داش راجل عمل يعني في نفس رمضان عنده
مسلسل بطولته على على شاشه قناه مهمه
كان عنده مين قال كان عنده مسلسل بطوله
احمد باشا
مهم وقصه الموضوع قائمه على محمد رمضان
واحمد باشا الراجل وابنه جعفر وابنه
انا مش شايف ان حتى لو حصل بعد ان ان اللي
حضرتك تقصديه ان منه قالت من دي اطيب
واحده في العالم ممثله رائعه وانسانه
جميله وهي واحمد اصحاب واخوات
بس وان كان احيانا ممكن الواحد يخونه
التعبير او يخونه الكلام او يبقى طمعان في
شيء اكتر فيلاقي حاجه او هي بتقيسها
بالاقدميه كل ممثل من حقه ان هو يتمنى
ولكن دي في الاخر تعاقدات وبتاع ده لا
ينقص من منا ولا يزيد من احمد ولا ينقص من
احمد ولا يزيد منه الاتنين اصحاب واخوات
وزملاء في عمل ناجح وبينهم كل احترام انا
عارفه انه لبسته من قبل ولبسته مرتين لانه
فستان بحبه وما عندي مشكله يعني فستان
موجود عندي وبحبه بلبسه وما فيك ترد الناس
سمعت الكلام عن الجراه وما الجراه يعني
حتى انت شخصيتك بتذكر كلمات يعني اعتبروها
البعض جريئه يعني
ما أشوف انه ارجع اقول يعني انه ماني
شايفه انه في اي شيء بالعكس لو استمرون في
المتابعه راح يفهمون القصه راح يفهمون
مبررات كثيره بس المشاهد يعني ما يقدر
يحكم من اول حلقات
واستحق اليوم اني اكون موجوده واستحق اني
اللي اخذ البطوله
هذا يعني هذا مكاني الحمد لله والشكر
فماما خذته من احد ثاني بنفس الوقت
الفرصه للشباب وللوجوه الجديده ما بيها اي
مشكله او خلل انه يطلع انه وجه جديد احنا
كنا زمان الجمهور بيتريق على الممثلات
اللي بيبقوا صاحيين من النوم شعرهم معمول
ميك اب وبيستحموا فدلوقتي الست واقعيه جدا
دي واحده عندها حدوته كبيره قوي فطبيعي
يبقى شكلها كده ما عندهاش وقت بقى لا تحط
ميك اب ولا حتى سوري يعني تعمل حواجبها هي
منى زكي دي من المدرسه الواقعيه المفرطه
هنرجع نشوف خالد يوسف خلاص مثلا نجم
النجوم رمضان دائما
العمليه مرهقه جدا جدا في حقيقه هذه
التغريده ايش اللي صاير وانا بصراحه انا
اصلا ما اعرف من الايدان للامانه يعني وما
اعرف يعني دخلت على الاكاونت لقيت انه هذا
الاشياء منشوره فاستغربت
على اكاونتك انت لقيتها منشوره
هل احد مهكر حسابي وكاتب لهذه
معتزازى بها بشخص الكريم ما اعرفها والله
بعدين دخلت على كاونتر لقيتها حاكي اشياء
بعدين معتذره بعدين حاكي اشياء وراح
انسحبت فما افتهم هاي المسكينه يعني عندها
مشكله الظاهر عائليه ماثر عليها وبعدين
فما شفت الموضوع يستاهل انه يحكي بصراحه
حضرتك ذكرت قلت انه صديقي وحبيبي ابو
راكان يعني عوده التعاون مع ناصر القصبي
بعد 12 سنه كان كيف كانت الكواليس بعد هذا
الغي
اب يعني خصوصا انه في فتره كانت فيها اخذ
ورد وقيل وقالوا خلافات يعني
في خلافات هي خلافات في وجهات نظر على
الانتاج والعمل والشراكه وما شابه وهذه
تحصل في كثير من الشركات من
شركات كبرى بنوك وما شابه هي خلافات بسيطه
وفي مرحله عمريه معينه هذه منتهيه لكن بعد
العوده
حقيقه يعني كاننا امس يعني كان 11 سنه
اختزلت في فتره سبع شهور او ثمانيه شهور
ما حسينا باي شيء يعني يبقى هو عرفني وانا
اعرفه يعني احنا عارفين بعض
وهدفنا في النهايه ان هذه السفينه ان تصل
الى الى المرفا او تصل الى بر الامان بشكل
مناسب وجيد عبد الله وناصر كيف يعني كان
هذا الشغل الشاغل لكن ابو راكان وعبد الله
اكبر من هذه الامور
مرحله متجاوزه وتم تجاوزها بكل اريحيه
وبكل بساطه
في اختيار ليله زاهر عشان تشاركك العمل
وطبعا يعني دائما في حديث كان عن خلافك مع
والدها الفنان الكبير احمد زاهر وقالوا
انه الاختيار ليله كان مفاجاه للجميع
وبعدين يعني انا شخصيا يعني وانا بتكلم مع
الفنان احمد زاهر وزوجته هدى كانوا
بيتكلموا كمان قديش انك انت كنت رائعه في
التعامل معاها وقديش انك انت احتضنتيها
فعليا هذا الاختيار كيف جاء
اولا ليلى كنت انا مختاراها من قبل ما
احمد يطلع في البرنامج ويقول ان في مشاكل
حتى انا نفسي
استغربت قوي انا واحمد عمران متخانقنا عمر
ما كان في بيننا خناقه حتى قصاد بعض كده
وزعقنا مع بعض فانا قلت اكيد اكيد حد وصل
له او حد قال له ده فبالتالي هو خد الخطوه
من غير ما يسالني فاهمه
بس
فلم ده حصل في الجموم قالوا لي طب انت
شايفه ايه يعني ليلى قلت لهم لا لا لا
ليلى هتيجي وليلى هتشتغل وبعدين دي مهنه
احنا يا جماعه انا مش الممثلين ابدا اللي
بصفي حسابات شخصيه
شغلتي
مهنتي دي اكل عيشي دي دي حاجه
كنت بحلم بيها طول حياتي هي اللي عملتني
فهل هنا ابقى ست ادخل في شغلي اصل مين قال
وفلان عادوا لا لا لا وبالذات ان بجد بجد
انا ما بكرهوش انا مش عارفه هو جايب
الكلام ده منين الحاجه الوحيده بس اللي
قلتها له قلت له احمد قبل ما تقول اتاكد
لان ممكن انا انا حكايتي عدت انا ست ذكيه
وخبرتي بسني ممكن ده يحصل مع حد تاني ما
يبقاش عنده خبرتي او ما يبقاش زيي فهماني
هتحصل بجد مشكله هو بس عشان يعني التوضيح
هو جاي الوقت انه تم استبعاده من عمل
بسببك يعني
فانت بتقولي انه لا هذا الشيء ما صار حتى
لا لا لا
اوكي لكن انا اتكلم في نقطه اني اشوفه هذا
جزء من الواقع يعني هذا كانت قاعده بنات
وكنا قاعد نتكلم عن شيء معين وان قالت
الكلمه بغض النظر صح ولا غلط لكن انا من
باب انه هذا اول شيء واقع هذا البوست اللي
انت كاتبه وبترد انه في على المغرضين
واللي بيحطوا كلام على لسانك وانه كل
الاحترام والتقدير للممثلين السوريين وما
الى ذلك ايش صار اللي خلاك توني تكتب هذا
البوست اللي صار هو انه صار في كلام
كتب كلام عن لساني انا مش قايله يعني
بكل مقابلات اللي مرقت فيها بهالفتره
الاخيره ولا مره انا جرحت ولا مره قلت انا
يا ريتني الممثلين السوريين عم بياخدوا من
تربه عم بياخدوا من دربي عم بياخدوا ادوار
البطوله ولا مره قلتها من زمان كان في بيت
موضوع معين وخلص وانتهى وخلص الموضوع انا
شفت كمان يمكن الناقده ماجده خير الله
كاتبه كانت انك اسوء شخصيه في المسلسل
وانه انت عامله شخصيه الشخص
اللي مغترب اللي جايبه انه بطريقه فيها
تخلف عقلي وعبط قديش جرحك هذا الكلام يعني
يمكن انتقادات بس هذا حسيتيه جارح اكيد
انا عايزه اقول لحضرتك حاجه استاذه ماجده
قبل كده مدحت فيا وقالت عاليه عليا ان انا
ممثله كويسه وممثله موهوبه فانا مش
متضايقه من الانتقاد ده زي ما قلت لك
بالعكس ده انا هتعلم منه وابقى احسن بسببه
فانا مش متضايقه منه ومش متضايقه من اي حد
قال اي حاجه على الدور ده لان انا عارفه
ده طبيعي انت ساعات بتعملي دور حلو قوي
وممكن بعد كده تعملي دور مش احلى حاجه
ليكي او مش لاقي عليك فانا انا متقبله جدا
الاراء دي وبالعكس انا بتعلم منها وانا
بشكرها ان هي قالت كده علشان اتعلم من
النقد ده ودائما بشوف ان النقد بناء يعني
انا هبقى احسن بسببك فانا مش متضايقه
وبالعكس هي قالت عليا كلام قبل كده حلو
واكيد هتقول كلام ان شاء الله حلو قريب
يعني يا ميان بيعكس نضج يعني صراحه انتوا
بتكرهوا جدا انا نسيتها خلاص يعني انا انا
بحاول بحاول اتعافى من سيد لان سيد كان
عامل لي مشكله
سيد كان عايش معايا ثلاث شهور اللي هو وقت
التصوير كنت انا وسيد بس عايشين في بيت
لوحدنا انا ما شفتش اولادي ما شفتش
اصدقائي ما خرجتش من البيت كنت بخرج بس
اجيب اكل اجيب حاجه وارجع تاني عايش في
البيت انا وسيد ببص في المرايه بلاقي سيد
بكلم سيد بذاكر وانا سيد طول الوقت انا
مركز كل التركيز ويا رب الحمد لله يعني
النتيجه الحمد لله يعني طلعت الحمد لله
على قد المجهود في عندك انت واحده قالت لك
انه دكتورك يبدو هو نفس دكتور هيفاء
وهعلقت على صوره لك في انستقرام انت رديتي
عليها وقلت لها جربي نفس الدكتور شوفي اذا
بتطلعي تشبهينا بس انه انا كفنانه انه كل
شوي لاقي تعليق وتنمر على موضوع التجميل
ولو ما كل الناس
العاديه سترات البيوت اللي هي ما بتطلع
الشاشه واللي ما هي الناس اللي بيشوفوها
كل وقتهم بتعمل تجميل فلي ش فليش انتم عم
تتنمروا على ممثله وفنانه هي لازم تكون
دائما
بالموت الازياء وبالشكل سيره بتقول انك
انت كثير داخل في عالم السوشيال ميديا انت
ما عندك واتساب كمان يا جورج كيف عايش كيف
معي هعيش معانا على هذا الكوكب
مضبوط والله عايش عايش عم بتنفس عادي
وسعيد اكيد مروج اكيد اسعد منا انا من
ناحيه انك انت مروج
والله انا عايش يعني انا عايش مع الطبيعه
بحب الطبيعه كتير بحب البحر بحب الشجر
وعايش ببلته هون بالبترون على الفيسبا
تبعي وعلى البسكليت تبعي فانا جدا سعيد
بالحياه الطبيعيه
رائع يعني انت بتعطينا مثال وبتذكرنا انه
في اسلوب مختلف للحياه السريعه اللي نحن
صرنا فيها والكلام هذا كله انت حضرتك عندك
تعليق او تحبي تضيفي شيء على هذا الموضوع
حقول حاجه واحده بس دايما الشجر المثمره
بيحدفوها بالطوب انا فاكره كويس جدا ان كل
الاعمال اللي انا عملتها اللي كانت ناجحه
وعملت بوم من اول اسبوع اتقال عليها نفس
الكلام
وهفكرك ونفس الكلام ده حصل في سبق الاصرار
وحكايه حياه والكابوس وحدو تمر نفس ده
بالضبط بالملي بدي اسالكم كده شويه اسئله
بس على المواضيع هل عندكم قضايا مرفوعه
عليكم انتم رافعين قضايا على احد
انا رافعه انت رافعه قضيه على مين
القضايا مالتنا اللي يعني في قانون ياخذ
مجرى
يعني
ايش التهمه في القضيه اللي
اخر قضيه الشكوى اللي مقدمينه اخر قضيه
كانت
تحريض الصحافه
الدوله تحرير صحافه خليجيه علي انا في
واتسابات بين الصحفي والشخص اللي انا
رافعه عليه
واحده هي لانه نشوف بعض المقاطع اظلموني
او اقطعوا رزقي سالفه الرزق هذه من الله
لا بيجي ولا بيدك واللي بيظلم يظلم نفسه
من ايده هذا شغله شغله ثانيه انا لو بطلب
اقطع الرز انا ترجيت عبد الوهاب العيسى
وهو حي يرزق موجود دشيت مكتبه في بوتيكات
وترجيته رجوى انه يدخلها بوتيكات وكنت
ماسكه تلفوني وايش سنابها واقول له أشوف
شوفي شلون مسرحيتها شوف العرض تكفى خلاص
خلاص ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ما دار
يومين الا وقعوها بوتيكات ابسط قطعه رزق
يا ساره انا من
اول وحده وقعت عقد بوتيكات كلمه مسموعه
لله الحمد في بوتيكات لو انا بقطع هالرزق
كان من باب وقطعت الرزق وقلت سكره واكلتها
صح ولا لا والله يا ساره شوفوا احنا في
الايام الفضيله ما فيها والله العظيم انه
بيني وبين يعني في نفسي وبيسمعوني اقول
حتى ما صار في خط رجعه
ما اتركوا اثر جميل ان الواحد يرد وفيه خط
رجعه يعني
خلاص يعني ذاك اليوم نسولف حق شهاب اقول
له يمكن الغلطه الاولى اعديها الثانيه
اعديها الثالثه
يصير بين الاهل وبين الحبايب ماكو مشكله
بس لكن في حدود وفي خط رجعه تصير ما كانش
موجود محمد علي اللي جابه من الهند دي بقى
فزلكه من طراز رفيع يعني يعني اعرض لك
تغريده ثانيه للناقد رجا ساير المطيري كان
بيقول فيها انه طاش المشروع يجب ان يستمر
انه مهما كان مستواه ولازم يتحول
لزيت لايف اللي مستمر صار له خمسين سنه
وناجح جدا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وطبعا حول العالم ايضا هل ممكن نتوقع انه
في جزء ثاني ويستمر هذا المشروع
العلم عند الشيوخ حقيقه يعني هم من جمعنا
وهم من
اسسوا طاش العوده وهذا الفكره
العلم عند ابو ناصر تحديدا يعني انا اتوقع
ابو ناصر
الشيخ وليد ابراهيم انا قلت في بدايه
اللقاء انه طاش هو اصبح جزء من الموروث
الشعبي السعودي لا اتوقع انه عبد الله
السدحان او ناصر القصبي في هذه المرحله او
بهذا العمر بحاجه الى شهره او
اضواء او ما شابه لا احنا المهم عندنا
كفنانين صادقين برساله لنحملها هو ارضاء
المتلقيته وكفيت ولا تبيني اكمل لا يعني
انت وفي
اجابه واضحه انه اذا بتتكلموا على جزء
ثاني ولا لا الصراحه هل ناقشوكم طيب
ما تكلمنا حقيقه
لا لا لكن انا مثل ما تفضلت انا
همي هو المتلقي همي هي الاسره يعني طاش
مثل ما ولا بدي التواجه وعيد انه يعني لو
قالوا لك
الشيوطي نشتغل على جزء ثاني السنه الجايه
حتقول اوكي
اكيد اني لا يمكن بقول لهم انتم فصلوا
وانا البس لكن حيكون لي بعض الشروط
البسيطه اللي هي في النص بن زينه زينه
زعلانه منكم فعلا في خلاف ولا لا لا ما
اعرفش لا ما اعرفش والله هي انا ما اعرفش
ممكن تكون عندها حاجه او ممكن تكون مش
موجوده انا معرفش يعني ايه هو هو بيدعو كل
واحد مننا لشخصه يعني كل واحد يوصل له
انديتيشن لشخصه ممكن تبقى تغيره ظاهره شخص
الاحترام طب انت انت شخصيا ما بينك وبين
اخي يعني
لا طبعا ليه خلاف ليه اعوذ بالله بالعكس
يعني الست بطله مسلسلي وعامله شغل جميل
جدا وانا مبسوط بالشغل ولا بالعكس ليه
يكون في خلاف اعوذ بالله الجنه المستمر
على موضوع زينه انت قلت انه ما عندك اي
مشكله مع زينب والكلام ده كله زينه طلعت
في برنامج الان والتصريحات عمليه كل مكان
تقول ما راح اشتغل مره ثانيه مع محمد سامي
خلينا خلينا ننجح في مسلسلنا ونتبسط
بنجاحه شفنا نجاحه مسلسلنا وبعدين نبقى
نشوف قصه زينه
[موسيقى]
يزعجها جدا
مش هتشتغل مع محمد سامي تاني انا انا في
الاخر عملنا مسلسل ناجح وربنا سبحانه
وتعالى كلامنا فيه ونجحنا واتبسطنا وعملنا
شغل كويس وهي نجحت عملت دور كويس ربنا
يسعدها بنجاحها ويبسطها بنجاحها وده قرار
يخصها هي هي هي اكيد لها وجهه نظر انا
بحترمها
اي امراه بعد ما نقول عراقيه او غيرها اي
امراه تتعرض للاساء ثم بالك انه انا
كعراقيه اقضي على هذا الشيء بس ما حسيتي
للحظه انه لا ممكن الموضوع ينفهم غلط انه
ليش ليش العراقيات طالعين في كدور عاملات
في عند مثلا كويتيات
امانه ما كان الموضوع مركز على هذا الجزء
طبعا يعني في كذا ريفرنس كان بذهني طب في
رفرنس جدليه معينه تقدر تحب تقول لنا هي
الحقيقه انا ضليت فتره طويله يعني مهتم
بشخصيه الرئيس صدام حسين انه يعني هو رجل
عنده كاريزما قويه جدا
اثنين هو الشخص ممكن يكون يعني غضوب وحاسم
بدرجه يعني تصل الى حدود قصوى من
القسوه يعني بيبقى يعني ردود فعله قويه
وحاسمه وممكن يدمر كل شيء حواليه
واحيانا بيبقى شخص متبسط ومستمع ومتامل
وممكن يكون صاحب نكته كمان بنفس الوقت فهي
الشخصيه يعني الحياه
غنيه جدا
طبعا عن موقفي انا السياسي من موقفي معروف
يعني انا كنت يعني على الدوام ضد سياسات
ضد غزو الكويت بالتاكيد احنا قاعد نسوي
حالات الطلاب حياتهم الطبيعيه كثر ما هي
الدراسه نشوف الاكشن وبالنهايه احنا دراما
لازم شويه نفتح فيها الخطوط هذه مبين شلون
الخليجي او العربي او اي شخص يسافر لندن
دراسه طبعا عنده اشياء بره فيها اكشن فيها
حب فيها اشياء سياسيه فيها دينيه فيها ايا
كان انه حياه يعني واكيد تابعت كمان الجدل
اللي على الموضوع انه الاساءه للمراه
العراقيه
نعم شفنا والعراق تاج على راسنا واحنا
نغار على العراق وما نوضع احد يغلط عليها
هلا
المسلسل انتهى
احنا طبعا بنتكلم عن قصه طلاق وسنين طويله
موضوع الطلاق
بصي انت وشك حلو عليا بس لانه انا انا
طبعا مش عايزه اقول لك انا تعبانه ومجهده
قد ايه لاني انا من الساعه 8:00 الصبح في
الشارع وطبعا نازله من سته ونايمه خمسه
لانه احنا الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
الطلاق تم
خلص الموضوع الحمد لله
والنهارده بالتحديد
رحت غيرت اسمي في الرقم القومي همم الاي
دي بتاعي يعني وغيرت الباسبور وغيرت كل
الاوراق يعني كل الاوراق القديمه اترمت
والنهارده كل اوراق جديده بس اليوم لما من
اول ما بدا عرض المسلسل الناس كلها كانت
بتقول هذا مسلسل جريء جريء جريء انصدمنا
من حجم الشفافيه والجراه في الحوار وفي
وصف يعني خلينا نقول اللي هي بتكون زي
المناوشات اللي بتصير بين اللبنانيين
والسوريين وحسسنا انها يعني فعلا واقعيه
يعني اللي بيصير في المشاهد لما قرات
السكريبت ما حسيت انه اوف هذا الكلام جريء
ما عمرنا عملنا شيء قبل كده زي كده
[موسيقى]
على فكره انا قلت الساعات لو طبقت في
التصوير في التصوير يومين او تلاته ورا
بعض ما اقدرش اصوم فيهم لاني باخذ ادويه
ادويه
كل اللي انا قلته ده ايوه كاتبين اصلها ما
بتصومش في رمضان لما بتشتغل
ممتاز غاده انك انت الان وضحتي هذا
الموضوع لانه العناوين فعلا كلها اجتزقت
جزء معين يعني فجيد انك انت وضحت هذا
الشيء طوني انتم بتلعب دور متطرف وهذا
المتطرف من دين غير دينك وممكن بعض الناس
ياخذوا هذا الموضوع بحساسيه ما وترك هذا
الموضوع
جدلي جدا زكريا منه طبيعي هذا الانسان منه
طبيعي
وكم هناك من اشخاص غير طبيعيين في الحياه
يعني بنظام الحياه ككل
فهذه الحاله الاستثنائيه هي موجوده بارض
الواقع
من ارض الواقع اذا بتاخذيني على الديني
بتقولي لي مثلا المسيحيين
لانه ما في انسان فوق راسه خيمه في كثير
ناس عنده الطرفين هيك وهيك
[موسيقى]